macht new workork glücklich der frag bin
ich auf me Reportage nochegang W ich sie
auf Berlin begleitet hab und
hatber zwip und zwi ich in der
Kommentarspalte gemerkt willkommen zum
Q&A
wirönar Kommentar wo ich V be der erste
Kommentar zum noch zeigen was für ein
zwi dasen ist vom Josh Wirt schribt
dankef dass ihr das Thema Push man B vor
4 jah geschäftsleitig abgeschafft und S
immer meh new work methodenführt das
beste wo wir bis jetzt gemacht h und
dann hte James wardy 6826 auf das so hey
ne B direkt Gegenteil wir sind sehr gut
D mit gefahre oldschool Arbeitsplatz
völlig strukturier die arbeitsabläuf und
generell arbeitssit mit klar definierte
Erreichbarkeit Arbeitsstunde und weekend
sind tabu also das wier spielt so B
Zwiespalt danke vi mal für Kommentar mal
und das G schlussendlich dass man drüber
kann diskutieren über das Thema new work
und es sind einige Frage V und die
möchte ich heute gern zammen mit dem
Experte mit dem Konrad wber besprechen
er ist Strategieberater new workk expert
und unterrichtet der HWZ scas zu newwork
und jetzt gerade mit
hallo ja mega viel kommentiert kan ich
einach mir so paar
kommentarepickt W ich gern h mit dir wir
besprechen und der erste kom gerade V
der heiß Jonas groß Music und er
schriebt händ Weg new work hört sich
extrem toll an in der Theorie ist in der
Praxis aber oft mit toxischen
Arbeitsverhältnissen verbunden sobald
man Grenzen setzt und auch mal Zeit für
Familie oder Freunde oder einfach gerne
für die mentale Gesundheit einfordert
hagelt das mit Vorwürfen ich bin froh
dass ich erst gerade einen new workk
Betrieb verlassen habe und einen
langweiligen N9 to5 Job angefangen
und
905ind DZT wird work Wiest du das ich
glaub jedes
Arbeitsmodell
toxis klassisch hierarchisch oder halt
wirklich neu wgend auf ausich Hierarchie
auf andere neu Reg irend setzt ich glaub
mega wichtig dass man das immer wieder
zum Thema macht und wirklich drüber R im
od wie eigentam schaffen und ich nicht
so sehr n new work Problem sondern
grundsätzlich Thema wo hezutags je mehr
Druck das zuunimmt mehr zruck und
irgendwie mehr das Mus Leist sowieso
ganz grundsätzlich ganz vi beobachten
ist mit der Community bedank sehr groß g
das be new work Konzept die Mitarbeit
ausgenutzt W aber gerade so frei Arbeits
sind und J James
288 ist kritisch er wird wssen woher das
Konzept und wenn n schlussendlich ist
wirk so dass die mitarbeiten profitiert
profitiert vor allem die inhaben
schlussendlich das Konzept schon relativ
alt wenn es verglicht mit de ganz
h V nach Corona irgendwie um das
themaftucht es geht zurück bis die 70er
80er Jahr wo s Strum gangen der Mensch
vom klassisch kapitalistische
arbeitsmodend befrei das mE individuell
ausw wie das schaffen und wir schaff
bestimmt und drum ist eigentlich
ursprülich sehr mench zentriert und
natürlich sehr viel un a und das
natürlich spannend wenn immer erreichbar
ist und immer irgend über nach schaff
und das verlangt wird von den das
durchus
natürlich du h
immer Abruf parat und mus gichtig nicht
irend zah oder irend Wochen Zulage oder
irgend ab oder nachzulage zah oder so
und umgekehrt geht Hal dass man aber
mehr Freiheit und Sichel und so
ist nste Kommentar der rechtsteiner
261 sie selber Schiet sie Möglichkeit V
dieus schaffen aber sie merke dass sie
wieo die V der Arbeits und den mega lang
PC ho schlussendlich will sie aber vor
spoutü gchaffen und dann macht sie
pünktlich viig gend so Technik wie man
sich new work trotzdem abgrenz wenn so
der Übergang zwischen freizit und Arbeit
fließendb beobachte gr W der starke
Phase von Corona im im 2020 wo ja
sowieso Hobbes und freizit Aktivität
vorft eig noch noch geschaff und
irgendwie B nachher irgendwn gchlaf oder
irgend auf netflixt oder so und die die
Grenze ja mega verwischt und das abgrenz
das ja das H Hal vielleicht schon
stärker W immer am gichen Ort blib und
da geht schon Technik dass das einfacher
F dass du vielleicht wen die möglich
sicher nicht im Schlafzimmer irgendwie
schaffst der geht schon die die größte
Schwierigkeit nach aber das
vizwischen nach dem
schaff vi no mit der Hand mach irendwi
oderend wirklich aus dem Kopf
irgendwie die Körper und der wirklich
Break machen oder aber d auch ganz
bewusst oder im Team bewusst
se Z fix aber irgendwie um zit wirklich
fertig und wird auch nicht verlangt dass
irgendwie nach auf M reagiert oder dass
man irgendwi denn nach wie vor
erreichbar mus oder so also dass man der
sich selber
vi
normal Grenze setzt und die Team
bespricht und so V mit der nächste
Kommentar richtet sich Inhaber in darum
hab ich geschrieben und von ihm der
Kommentar beantwortte und zwar sch die
Person was ist denn bei new work die
durchschnittliche monatliche Arbeitszeit
und steht diese auch im Verhältnis zum
Lohn mir auf das geantwortet und seit
das Arbeitszeit bis normals ander aber
Flexibilität W Arbeit den machen wenn
man möchte es geht Mensche die schaffen
z.B lieber am Morgen im Büro und andere
bevorzug Nacht zum Schaffen ma ich das
jede Person so wie es für sie oder ih am
best passt nächste Kommentar W
ichestellt hab und zwar h Don Person eü
Eiswelle W ST nicht für Nachhaltigkeit
das Firma aber schnell mal mit dem Team
nach New York Flüge finde sie äußerst
fraglich und auf das
hteantwortet seit viele junge l
Nachhaltigkeit wichtig auch inen also
Sie wenn möglich setz sie darum auf
öffentliche Verkehrsmittel das galt die
vor allem ver oder Team Events wie
z.bon der Reportage Berlin Gang sind
oder auf Italien wo sie zwei Wochen
machen aber New York das ist natürlich
nicht gangen mit dem Zug und in New York
gab Sache W finde Gabi unter anderem
sind sie LinkedIn tiktok oder
snapchat und ke wartvoll Informationen
für ih Kunde im Gepack
mittein so wie Frage und dann komen wir
e zu näste Frage dir wird g Krad Weber
Reportage und ich me gemkt W ich mit S
Berl ist irendwie schon nicht für alle
der Lifestyle oder das Arbeitsmodell
und der kommentarspal sind sie sich
einig D nicht alle Z ST schriebt wenn
man jung ist sind fr alles den B new
work perfekt spestens aber wenn man
Familie h den möchte nicht 247 mit
Arbeitskollegin und
Arbeitskollege junge Mens
zeig sehr extrem W jetzt mal sagen wo es
wirklich so wirkt als war die
24cation in Berlin Recht und ist
natürlich schon so jünger bist
vielleicht eher noch
bereit ja einfach aus dem gruppef irgend
mit und du h vielle privat UMF Arbeit
dubringst mega viel miteinand und VI
mach nach auch z miteinander das
verbindet ja extrem aber werde
tatsächlich nach andere verpfichtig
selbst W vi nach oder so den wir größer
sch und mus irgendwo ne sag n Kommentar
vom Adam cpple
689t sie Sekte und kultartige tendenze
Struktur und
Ideologie so sekar tendenze W
dasobachtet
Reportage zeigt V durchus Gefühl hat
dass das irende so einew Truppen ist und
mega h überhaupt in und man kennt sich
in und auswendig und das ist Element wo
wo man Gefüh das ist jetzt irgend Sekt
oder so ich glaub es ist wichtig
differenzieren dass es ja nicht immer n
so muss also man durchus Element von
newk ohne D man
mit Hut und Haar irgendwie muss der also
man ja
durchus abgrenzig machen es zwingt de
niem dazu früher Morgen Sport no müss
machen oder
irgendwieb oder so aber ja es hat
natürlich schon eine gewisse
Gruppendruck womit schwingt und wenn
irgendwie oder zwei Personen sich da
vielleicht immer wieder offer wäre den K
irgendw zu und Aspekt
obwohl das sehr viel
verschiedene mit un und so
doch Typ men
allass
offheit Konzept gegenüber und das zeigt
vi
[Musik]
Schag das ist ja
realits
akzeptieren
Recht und zwar V
RA homeice im geschaft aber das n der
Schwiz arbeitsrechtlich Sicht schwierig
ist v Ausland
schaffen ist das sich z.B einfach in
Thailand oder span absetz schaff
[Musik]
oder aus Arbeits rechlicher grü oder
versicherungstechnische grü nichtlbt wor
im Ausland schaffen und mit der ja
vorsicht aber es h Hal auch eine andere
Komponent Alin noch die jistische und
zwar die V der wirkig W du irgendwie vom
Strand irgend
zuschautbüro D vi funktionieren wo man
sich irgende auf das geinigt und das für
okay aber für größernmen odermen wos
lute zwungen sie immer am gichen Ort
müss schaffen wo es nicht anders geht
dann l es Hal sehr schnell nieus und
dann h recht großere Diskussion und
vielle ja es geses K zwis der
mitarbeiten innerhalb von Organisation
und das wird nach um so schwieriger
danke dir viel mal das war alle
Kommentar jetzt mit merci dass du dir Z
h sehr gern merci dir mach gut Ciao
danke tschüs das war mit dem Q&A danke
viel mal fürs zul und mer für die viele
Kommentare für die viele Feedbacks für
die liebewur für die kritische Stimme
habe mich sehr drüber gefreut und ein
Kommentar würde ich jetzt gerne zum
Schluss mit
ich da ich ein super cool gefunden und
zwar der Valerio V 4523 schriebt und er
bezieht sich da wahscheinlich aufcation
er schriebt oh mein Gott ich möchte mit
Meer Arbeitskollege nicht mal
Mittagspause machen ich das super
ja so sind halt alle spitel anders danke
vi fürs zulen und bis zum nächsten
Mal